gastonia north carolina ، حصد الفيديو
أكثر من 5 ملايين مشاهدة ، بدا
وكأنه فيلم من أفلام ديزني تمامًا مثل بلدة صغيرة
خارج توك فيلم ديزني أو
أوليفيا جارسيا وعائلتها كانوا في
كارولينا للتحقق من تساقط الثلوج مؤخرًا
عندما شاهدت هذا الفيديو  لقد أقنعت
عائلتها بالتوقف وكنت مثل ،
انتظر ، هل يمكننا التوقف في هذا
المكان المسمى gastonia لأنني رأيت للتو
هذا القراد ويبدو جميلًا جدًا
من فلوريدا غارسيا غير محاطة
بالجبال وسعدت بها
الفرصة لرؤيتهم
ثم فجأة وصلنا إلى هناك
وركضنا محطات الوقود فقط كما لو كان علينا الذهاب إلى
الحمام ولم يكن هناك حمام
يعمل في أي من محطات الوقود ،
لم يكن هذا ما توقعته.
قد لمدة ساعة بعيدًا عن الطريق قبل الميلاد من هذا
القراد الذي يؤرخ لرد فعلها
، حيث حصل فيديو غارسيا في غاستونيا الفعلي على
آلاف المشاهدات.
لقد حازت مقاطع الفيديو على
الكثير من المشاهدات ،
هذه من رحلته إلى سويسرا التي
بلغت مليون 2 مليون والآن ما يصل
إلى 6 ملايين حول أنه كان من
الجنون الآن جذب انتباه
رئيس بلدية غاستونيا
كما يقول على ما يبدو أننا
حديث المدينة  وعلى الرغم من أن غاستونيا ليست سويسرا بالتأكيد ،
فنحن سعداء لأن الناس
يتعلمون المزيد عن مدينتنا العظيمة ،
يسعدنا أن نرى الكثير من الناس يستمتعون
مع منشور زاكاري كاسي ونأمل أن
تعود ملكة جمال غارسيا لرؤية كل
الأشياء الرائعة التي تتمتع بها مدينتنا
في الواقع إذا كانوا يريدون الاتصال بي ، فأنا
أحب أن أمنحهم جولة شخصية
وأظهر لهم ما الذي يجعل مدينتنا علامة ، لذلك
أنا متأكد من وجود أجزاء جميلة منها ،
لذا سأعود 100 مرة ولم أتوقف أبدًا
في  مدينة وأنت تعلم أعتقد أن الوقت قد حان
للقيام بزيارة